[Music]
what up guys and welcome back to the
great era it's tuesday with me
your co-host sarah garvey
and also the woman who is currently
nuclear bombing on your internet
algorithms right now
pal just belly things that's me
[Laughter]
that is her today we got a good show for
you today um we'll be talking about
our father's appreciated but
before we even get started pearl
if you have not tell them
or if you have watched two or more of
our videos tell them
and you have not subscribed uh-huh then
we got what beef what we got pearl b
exactly so you better get subscribing
right now over to you belle all right
guys um a couple announcements before we
start the stream the first being that we
have two new clips channels the first is
just pearly clips and the second is
pearl daily shout out to you guys for
getting us to 50 000 subscribers on our
clips channel in a month and um 10 000
subscribers on our second second clips
channel in just a couple of weeks on top
of that today is a members only live
stream to be a part of the members to be
a part of the live sign up for the five
dollar tier on top of that if you want
to be a part of the
if you want to see what our behind the
scenes look looks like and see what this
brand new penthouse that we got looks
like sign up for the 10 tier that that
way you get to have access to behind the
scenes vlogs our third tier is to
connect with us on social media and our
fourth tier is to get a one-on-one
consultation with me once a month some
people use this to you know get life
advice and other people use it for
youtube help either is good you know
also go follow my instagram it's just
dot pearly things you have to type in
the whole thing because i'm shadow band
on instagram right now
right now i'm almost a 50k on top of
that guys go follow my fourth tick tock
because they took away my first tick
tock my second tick tock and my third
tick tock they can't get rid of you but
they can't they can't get rid of me so
that's just just dot pearly things four
and just pearly things dot five um on
top of that we're going to be doing a
members only live stream at the end of
the month and dm eddie if you want to
get on the show the link to his
instagram is in the description
so um today we have a lovely panel yes
we do um so let's go around and can you
say your age your name
relationship status and a fun fact about
you will start you do
my name is andy thomann i'm 31 years old
i'm in a relationship for four years now
and i guess my fun fact is uh i've
competed in the world case tag
championship i'm a parkour athlete
okay
hi my name's alia
i'm 24 years old
and my relationship status is i'm single
and a fun fact about me is i'm a medical
student so i'm training to be a doctor
at the moment
hi good evening everyone my name is rem
i'm 31 years old married
fun fact about myself um i run a snail
farm over in africa so if anyone wants
to eat any snails let me know
wow okay wow
yeah
hello um my name is aiden i'm 36 years
old
i'm single and the fun fact
i have traveled to more places than my
whole entire bloodline put together from
the beginning of man time i'm being
serious i've traveled to more places
around the globe than my whole entire
family put together wow wow
okay
um all right so let's get started um
fathers
first question is in society do you
think that motherhood is valued more so
than fatherhood
jump in let us know
absolutely
um
i can talk from personal experience i'm
a father
myself three kids twin boys and a girl
and i had a father
and
the way society is viewing men
um like i've previously heard on the
show it's like were disposable
the way society has built up women into
the destruction of the nuclear family at
its expense
it's also been a detriment to society
and
for that very fact we've become less
appreciated
and it's the results it doesn't play out
with society we're seeing more people
coming from single parent homes end up
in prison or seeing
more
bad people in society coming from single
homes so
to its detriment unfortunately we're not
appreciated
as a kind of citric society
yeah but you only
not appreciate it if you're a terrible
father
you're only appreciated if you're a
terrible father you're only not
appreciated if you're a terrible father
there's a
there's a variety of elements that
contributes to being incompetent man of
being a father one of them abandoning
your children the other one being there
when you feel like it not when you need
to be
i'm not a father i have no children i
speak like i do honestly i have to be
honest about that and something maybe
comes natural to me but so be i have
children in my family i have my sister
she's married she has children and so on
and i and i have a father i have a
father from day one so
there's certain elements that
contributes to being a incompetent man
of being the father and these people
just the people in general use those
elements
and apply them generically to all men
consistently and that's why society
assumes that men are incompetent at
being fathers and they value females
more that's one of the main contributing
factors so i'm just to clarify you're
saying that because of the bad fathers
they just assume it's all of them yeah
because in my experience i find that
there's
a lot of
good fathers that don't have access to
their children
and a lot of times like women are
spiteful
and don't give them access and then
they'll call them deadbeats but they're
not really deadbeats it's just because
the women won't give them access to
their kids
they're not part of the equation of
being an incompetent father right but
but to me like
i would say they are because a lot of
times like it's a different perception
when when they're like when the kids are
younger they think their dad's a
deadbeat but he's not and they find out
when they're 25 or 30. yeah
100
yeah i've got i've got a friend
personally actually he was talking about
this the other day
and unfortunately he's on the hook for
child support
that for uh for a daughter that
he hasn't seen
since she was born he signed the way his
rights
when he was in fact forced to to pay
for the child he tried to connect with
the child
with uh the the young daughter she's now
i believe 15 years old but due to the
poisoning of the mom
why did he santa raise rights
young
young he i think
well i know
in doing so being young naive not really
knowing the consequences of doing so and
thinking you know
a lot of guys make well they make
mistakes take account for it but
in the hope that signing away the rights
because i believe she was a she she
wasn't from this country so one of the
main reasons so she could leave the
country but in essence she left and came
back started claiming and got him on the
hook although he signed away so when he
tried to establish a relationship
uh the poison was already set in the in
the young girl's heart so
up until now she he's not been able to
see her well so yeah you were gonna say
something um yeah so i think if you're
signing away your rights as a father at
a young age like it's natural for a
mother to already think like okay he
he's not putting in the effort to want
to be the father to this child at that
time as you said like he changed his
opinion so you probably didn't want to
like be that involved in the child's
life at the time so i think as a single
mom if you're then raising a child doing
all those things that that a two-parent
household should really be doing it's
natural to have that
toxic feeling yes you shouldn't say it
on the child or portray it to the child
but i think any person
normally sometimes slips up and they
will say things to the children which is
you're saying they're like poisoning the
idea to the child but also i
to do with the first question i don't
think that society is saying that um men
shouldn't be appreciated i think society
wants men to be appreciated but a lot of
men aren't doing enough to be able to be
appreciated i think the same way we have
like mother's day we have father's day
but not as many men are celebrated on
father's day because not as many men are
playing that role in father's day or um
or playing that role of actually being a
father to their child and a father
doesn't mean someone who's just okay i'm
gonna pay the bills and be a provider
you need to have an emotional connection
do you think that's the woman's fault or
the man's which one sorry if if there's
a father that's not involved in in the
kid's life whose fault is that
it's the person who doesn't want to be
involved in the child's life wouldn't
you wouldn't you say it's the mom's
fault for picking him because a lot of
times i see women picking guys that have
you know three three kids by three
different women and then being shocked
when he's not a good dad
i think that's definitely can be the
case so i think people do need to choose
their partners very wisely because at
the end of the day that's who you're
having a child with and you want to
raise your child with but obviously
people have get into situationships
people fall pregnant things happen and a
lot of men change as well when they find
out that a woman's pregnant they can be
the most loving
man ever he could have loved bomb dude
making me did you fall in love with his
potential everything else and we love
bombing what is that it's like we're at
the start of a relationship or you start
talking to a guy and he tells you
everything you want to hear like
what we were saying before basically men
women fall in love with what they hear
so men know that so they'll tell you
everything that you want to hear
you'll fall in love with that potential
hoping he'll be that guy whose fault is
that
whose fault is that yeah to fall in love
with what you hear i just i don't i
don't really buy it when women say they
don't know
i just think it's a little crap
like you know damn well that
you know damn real
that
like the guy is who he is they see the
million red flags and they just don't
care
i'm sure you've been as a woman you've
seen red flags and just ignored them
right yeah
i've definitely been in that situation
but i think that comes down to you as a
person for me i want to see the good in
people so okay i've seen some red flags
but i also i've seen good green flags as
well and you want to hope that the green
flags will overtake the red flags yeah
but you like red flags i don't like it
like
yeah anymore i think it's an immaturity
thing liking red flags liking immature
men it's just when you're immature and
you haven't gone through that
self-growth to realize there's better
but because so many men have red flags
it's hard to find a man who doesn't have
any so you're just trying to find a man
with the least number of people
do you think that's a little bit sexist
like what if they were here saying that
oh all these women have all these red
flags and it's really hard to find a
woman that doesn't have any red flags
men say that as well i would say by and
large not the same not as much as women
do no because men say women are toxic so
that's the equivalent of saying that do
you really feel like it's equal in
society
that was equal that is equal like men
and women equally dog in each other
i think um
i think
yeah i think in the uk they they both
dog each other
men are trash what is that do you think
like like okay so
if we if we're under a mantra of
menotrash men are dogs men are deadbeats
right how does that play out into
fatherhood you see so when it comes to
the man's role in the household if if we
are being told women are being told and
they're telling their girlfriends that
men are trash men are dogs men are
deadbeats how do you think that plays
out in the way in which women see men
once they have their children
um so i don't say menotrash i think some
men are trash i wouldn't generalize that
to all men definitely a large proportion
of men i've experienced the trash i'm
not going to talk on other women's
experiences
but i think
why do you think that is why do you
think that a large proportion of men
that you personally experience she's
like she likes red flags i don't like
red bags why were they the ones you've
experienced before before when i was
immature younger i would go for guys
with red flags that's just due to it
when did you stop would you say what age
you're 24 so when when did you stop at
the start of this year i got therapy so
i i understood why it hasn't been lost
yeah it hasn't been long it hasn't been
long no but there's a definitely a
difference now i know what i like now so
like about a year around 24 that was
yeah okay so if you if you were picking
trashmen
right and then you got a trash result
right
um a lot of the time that what exactly
what pearl was saying women pick trash
men get trash results and then say men
are trash and it's like it's not because
men are trash because you pick trash men
because the pool of men that you're
choosing from are trash
do you know what i mean so that mantra
of
men of trash is because the majority of
women are dealing with trash men because
the majority of men are trash men no so
i think the pool is a large pool of
trash man okay so well maybe speak for
yourself maybe the men you do i know a
lot of great men no i know a lot of
great mentors but i still think the
majority are i would say i would say
that's not true i don't think the
majority of them actually
it actually matters who raised those men
but you don't know who raised them
so they're trash
so statistically right um 80 of women
choose 20 of men when they asked about
their ideal partner right so 80 of women
there's a pool of 20 of men roughly
right who women want okay so 80 of women
are dealing with 20 of men and that's
the reason why women think that men are
trash because those 20 of men have 80 of
women to choose from so they're gonna
exit a lot of them are going to exercise
those options with those 80 of women so
a lot of the time when you were saying
oh the men that i dealt with were trash
you're dealing with trash men yeah of
course right okay so when you say the
majority of men are trash you said the
majority of men are trash but it's not
just my experience no but the majority
of men are good men
the majority of men are good men but you
don't you don't want that like one one
in three one on three men are either
virgins or haven't had sex in the past
year if girls wanted a guy that could be
faithful they could find one but that we
don't want them so for if we're getting
cheated on it's literally our own fault
because we picked the guys that can get
a bunch of girls check your comments
wait are you on about like
men in the uk one but in the western
world western western worlds one and
three
sorry they're either virgins or have it
under 30. one in three men under 30 are
either virgins or haven't had sex in the
past year so what i'm saying is like a
lot of times girls will say things like
men are trash men cheat
but literally like only five to 15 maybe
20 of men can cheat so if we're picking
the guys that cheat how can we complain
when we get cheated on you picked them
because why would we pick men just
because they don't cheat we want men who
don't cheat who have a good job you have
everything else today right but i'm
saying if you if you want to if you
wanted them you would pick them they're
right there are guys but there are guys
that have good jobs that don't cheat you
could get an engineer you get a computer
software engineer okay they're not
they're not known
there were 50 guys that you would pass
today didn't even notice
you know those regular guys the guys
that work at starbucks the guys that are
taking the bins out the guys there's a
guy in my front security desk you see
right
you literally walked past 50 guys today
that you did not even
care about because they didn't match
that top 20 of men that you're looking
for so why should we have to sacrifice
the rest of what we want just because he
he doesn't he doesn't cheat why does why
does the top 20
have to cheat that doesn't make sense
just because i have everything else you
don't have to cheat
you're asking me because i think you're
living in a fairy tale because you're
you lived in a disney princess world
that's told you you can have everything
you don't get to have everything i don't
think but i'm saying i'm saying men and
women both have to compromise on things
that they want they probably want girls
that haven't slept with a million people
but that's not really common in the
western world
so
go ahead but you also have to look
what's the age category of the men that
you're approaching because if they're 30
over they should be much more mature
than being trash
i don't think age makes a difference it
does in men 100
million
men
underdeveloped if they do not get taken
care of hundred percent every single
male is underdeveloped if they do not
get proper fathering and then they grow
up in a man's body that can kill people
and then they go out become neanderthals
and their minds are children there you
go there you go so are you saying that
um in order for a man to be a proper man
a good man uh he needs to be raised by a
mother and the father 100 yeah
definitely i believe the idol situation
i believe is for a man to be raised by
both parents but i but but more
importantly i think one of the most
important things for a boy is to have a
male father figure in their life and
we if we're talking about this we're
talking about the subject today if you
look at the media and you look at tv
shows and you look at what is portrayed
as a father figure right in
tv shows and stuff like you look at the
simpsons
you can look at family guy
right these are bumbling idiots they're
bumbling guys and it's normally them the
women in the relationship which is the
smart ones and they're like oh we know
that guys are stupid and it's like oh
i'm just gonna be a bumbling idiot and
just grab a beer and go and do
that is a that is what women and men and
young boys are being shown what a father
is and i think the masculinity when it
comes to fatherhood has been removed
from society which is why we have such a
problem with the young males it also
helps to know all devices is available
at your disposal the negative vice if
you know all of it you can prevent your
child succumb to that vice that's
important before it becomes the
degenerate it's easy to become in
contemporary society
100 years ago we didn't have much to do
it was easy to be raised by a village if
your father died your father dies now
you're selling crack
you're selling crack right now not goats
so i want to go back to something you
said when you said you think the
majority of men did you say bad or you
said the majority of men are something
no i said the majority of men that i had
experienced the trash but you did say
the majority of men are trash okay so so
questions yeah do you do you also feel
like the majority of women are trash
yes okay so you feel like it's equal you
just think about it are you are you
included in that category definitely not
definitely you wanna
isn't that highly convenient right now
but that's the thing also because i'm
saying not all men are trash i've come
across a lot of really good nice guys a
lot of my friends that are male i
wouldn't put them in the category of men
or trash but the experiences a lot of
experiences i've had my friends have why
don't you date them because they're not
physically my type it's not their
personality it's just that i have a
friendship with them right and i'm not
physically attracted to them but you see
they are physically attractive just not
my type right but you see what i'm
saying like there are guys that would
treat you well in your friend zone
no no this was before so since since
i've changed
like if i came across a man that was
everything i wanted a good job like
respectful all those things 100 i would
go for him i'm not looking for red flags
i'm too old for them like i'm literally
24 like this is their age i want to be
wifed up i don't want to be
i don't want to be with a red flag i
know you think all women will love red
flags like that's it
i don't know i don't think all women
like reflections i think women are
attracted to red flags yeah but i think
that's immaturity to be attracted to no
i think it's just honest i've got a
theory on this that i've
worked on for a while i think
i can perfect it so my idea do you need
a whiteboard
yeah she's got a whiteboard
i saw that one
i'll just articulate as much as i can so
i i i work in the
in the nightlife industry security
industry so i'm i'm kind of privy to how
sexual dynamics works um a lot of the
times
and i see what i see
from personal
um observation
you're seeing a lot of girls a lot of
young pretty girls getting with
the dealers
the drillers
the
the fraud stars
everything that
in some so some way these kind of guys
gather for themselves
in a holistic way so what i mean by that
is
these guys display a
sense of economic wealth money
number two
they explain they
they exude an aura of somewhat power
these are the individual things that
young girls are attracted to all women
by that but the thing was with these
these men these men are normally getting
it very young at age
but they're displaying things that a man
normally works to
at the average age of mid 30s 40s and
what by me what i mean by that you get a
footballer for example um i work in the
sports industry as well so i see this
firsthand
a lot of the things that they get comes
very quickly well fame
status
by 18 20. right you could be famous
they would have a flock of women at
their disposal
but the average man doesn't attend to
the status until he hits his average
averagely mid-30s to 40s
so
some of these men are displaying what it
would normally take an established man
to have very younger age but what women
fail to realize that these guys are
still boys right they've not matured to
a level where they can understand
the power that's given to them status
wise and how to deal with women and it's
like blocking a man from a sweet shop
all his life and allowing him he's got
to go crazy there's no boy i can i can
relate to this at a young age when
you're afforded the ability to to be
attracted to women
you don't know how to handle it at times
so women get with these type of guys and
complain
why is this happening but they don't
know a lot of these men who attain this
somewhat street fame and uh
financial
uh
status
they don't know that this comes short
for a man and say his early twenties to
these type of people but they're still
kids so then what type of father would
that child or that young man normally
that goes on to my point of the subject
normally these guys are fatherless
because
um from an idol and personal experience
i know guys like this you know i've
grown up with guys like this and
i see it and probably up until this day
i still see the fact that
when you're when when there is a lack of
father when there is a lack of father in
the home
um
you don't have a good exam you don't
have a example so to speak of how to be
a man
a child looks at his father i remember
the way i used to look at my dad growing
up and he was everything i wanted to be
once you get into a certain age but his
traits rub off on you he's work ethic
he's discipline he's authority he's
masculinity he's manhood when a boy
doesn't have that at home he finds it
elsewhere right he finds it in community
he finds it in the streets because every
child is looking for a figure
every child is looking for in females
and males
and when men don't get at home they find
it elsewhere and unfortunately so do you
think there's a lack of
masculine
good steady
father figures right now abso absolutely
absolutely do you do you think that's a
do you think that's what's portrayed or
you think that's real life it's it's
portrayed and it's real life like you
gave the example of the simpsons i
remember i grew up within simpsons and
i remember seeing home as funny as he
was this this wasn't my dad you know
personally and this wasn't my father
figure he was just a comedy ad but a lot
of people see this especially for the
ones who don't have dads
they see it they grow up on it although
it is comedic it is an example of how
men are portrayed in in society and when
they grow up without
such a male figure that that they can
look up to
you get what you get
you know um
i um
my father
is a prime example of
the thing that i was supposed to avoid
essentially um
i don't know my father since i was like
my father left me and my mom when i was
one year old
and
my mom always told me that
he was allowed to always like be part of
my life even if he wasn't part of her
life
um and she was expecting him to do so
but he just wasn't when i was like i
don't know like four or five years old i
got like um
a cheap
toy motorcycle
and then i
that was it that was like the one time i
heard
from him until i was like 16.
um and then
he met me just
so that he can give me my signature so i
can
change my name
um and after that change it to his name
change it to my mom's family name right
wow i was on his name um and and then he
was like
he beat he bit himself in the chest with
his fist like oh i want to buy you a
guitar or something like that i want to
spend more time with you and i'm like
i don't believe that but you know i'm
going to stay quiet see what you're
going to do
that never happened again
uh again i haven't heard from him since
i was like fair enough now
funnily enough i actually had um a
message from my mom saying your dad's
been looking for you and i'm like
look i'm 31 years old now
i've achieved more in my life
that than he achieved in his
i i know
i know how he ended up i'm not curious
to be part of his life and i was like
i'm not interested
i think i think that my mom was a better
role model a better masculine role model
for me than my dad could ever been
are you saying
that your mother had to fulfill that
role she had to she had no choice right
because um
otherwise but in the ideal world
you would have preferred it to be him
no
i would have preferred it to be someone
else that has a bit of
cojones
yeah you know a bit more responsibility
look at me i'm 31 years old i don't have
a child because i've been responsible
i've been i've been engaging in sexual
activities
responsibly um
i've been protecting myself you know
like
i'm not married because i haven't found
the right person you know i'm not
jumping in
you know willy-nilly into
whatever situation just you know so i
can be a father
i'm waiting for the right moment and i
feel like
he's made all the mistakes that he could
have possibly made
and
and he was a role model for me in terms
of what not to do
right
so when it's time for you to become a
father you know what not to do
yes right
if somehow by accident let's say
unlikely but by accident i have a kid
i just i guess i have to just drop
everything it's not about my life
anymore you know i can talk from
personal experience because i share the
same sentiments as you because i was
raised without my father and um he was
he disappointed me and he had like five
children that he disappointed so it
wasn't just me
but what it done to me is that it made
me understand what i don't want to be
like but a lot of the times when it
comes to fatherhood and children who
don't have fathers
is that they turn out just like their
fathers they do the same things you know
they repeat the same cycles that their
father did so i just commend you on that
so you know well done keep going just
just to say
this is
this is an example like just because my
father was like that
doesn't mean that society should look
down on fathers as a whole
you know because then you instill that
sentiment
and then
men
think like
oh well everyone else is doing it you
know
why are you looking at me for and and
that gives them the opportunity to
for them to be irresponsible
we should encourage people we should
like
we should encourage like fathers like we
we should we should see fatherhood the
same way as we see motherhood because
then we avoid all these problems you
know because i'll i'll read something uh
because in 2020
2020 there were 15.3
million children
in the united states
with
a single mother without a father in
their life
and the amount of single fathers there
were is 3.2 million
so single motherhood like when i asked a
question before like do mothers you know
get seen as the better parent if a child
did you say something
yeah if a child does get into a
situation where he has to go with one of
the parents it's normally the mother
that they go with well women are
incentivized to do that because they get
more child support if they get if the
father gets less custody
and so like we'll complain all day about
men not being in you know the kids lives
or whatever
um and not not the years it was a
different situation but like we're
literally paying women to not to get the
father out of the home
even even i had um auntie on here auntie
jenny yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
she was saying how like
back in her day that if they were the
girls wanted to move out of the house
they'd just get pregnant because the
government would give him a apartment
is that a good way to bring a child into
the world
and it honestly just speaks to like
women nowadays
you
know my mom told me
my dad
did not give any sort of money no no
alamo no nothing you know and um i was
thinking about it like [ __ ] if something
happens if if i inherit something you
know because at the end of the day he
was my father
what should i do and and i came to the
conclusion out of integrity i have to
refuse it i have to refuse anything that
that man gives me
because that then it means
that like i'm just
i'm just unable unable to to make my own
future without you know without him like
out of principle you've you haven't been
there i don't need your
you know what are you doing i don't know
you know i would take it yeah me too
it depends how much yeah it depends how
much
a few casinos and that i mean
i understand
he wouldn't he wouldn't
nothing that he could give me
would be enough
for me to justify
giving away my integrity okay
he's he's not successful so how would it
how how has it sorry affected
you not having your father around i it's
been hard because uh
i i didn't as a child i didn't know how
to be masculine
um i would get beaten up bullied a lot
at school i i would be afraid to fight
back i had the
glass
made of glass syndrome you know i was
afraid that if i
if i punch something someone like
they would just shatter because
i don't know like i just
was not taught to defend myself
my mom
you know
she couldn't really
educate me on that side of stuff so it
definitely had an impact on me i had to
i had to learn
everything i had to learn from the
streets
i had to
go through the hard bits you know
get robbed get beaten up um
and and it was a grueling grueling
situation
uh i think i came out of it
quite well and quite um
it could have been worse i could have
come out real
i think your story is you know one of
the reasons why we say fathers are so
important you know i think society
pushes fathers out of the home if you go
to the um
fathers for justice website it shows
that 200 children per day are removed
from their
father
by the family court system um
so i think the society doesn't really
value
fatherhood for so many fathers to be
removed and i think it's very easy
for they pay you yeah they pay you to do
it
so you're literally paid out to be a
single mother so i have i have two
points to make the first one is
all children born uncivilized someone
has to civilize these children
so if you're two people who are drug
addicts then you can uh conceive a child
is it irresponsible of you to conceive a
child and the circumstances you are
or is it unfair on the child okay if
you're if you
i'm gonna just do them one at a time so
you said if you're both drug addicts
yeah it's irresponsible to have a child
i would agree yeah okay so we all know
where that's going to go with the child
when they're conceived right yeah we all
know
anomaly happens i don't want to be an
anomaly
okay and where i work i get to see a lot
of birth certificates
and
my life is social experiments in general
so i pick up on little things a lot of
single mothers don't have their father's
names on the birth certificate of their
child
i'm i'm sorry if i'm a father i want to
see my name on that what are you doing
i'm sorry what are you doing where's my
name on that that is my child
like how disrespectful would that be
what do you think of this man that just
inseminated you and then you conceived
the child and then you don't even put
his name on it yeah are you like serious
because men are not respected yeah and
then who's who is that well i i also
think it's like they say it's a form of
hypergamy because the girl doesn't want
to be associated with that man's last
name
because that's not the best she could do
you're happy to have sex and get your
vagina filled up i i didn't say it's a
good idea
i didn't say i recommended it i'm just
like i've been saying this to people
someone are raising these people like
this yeah somebody's raising this
consistent cycle because
if you grow up in a household with mom
and dad are married they are presenting
you the examples of relationship between
two people who raising children and if
you have a good good relationship with
your mom and your dad or whatever you
think it is you tend to adopt those
relationships and take into your life as
an adult
most women have a great relationship
with their fathers they tend to bond
with men most of the time and once men
who have a good relationship with their
mothers they tend to have a good
relationship with females along the way
especially if the environment they're in
isn't violent abusive
drug-related it's it's you don't need to
be millionaire you don't need to be
extremely educated basic level of
parenting
provides that
yeah but of course just to modernize
society they don't encourage marriage
like we've got this um
feminism is the enemy of marriage in
fact that i i think it encourages women
to
in some way live up to them a man's
metric
and sorry what are you gonna
um so i have a question um why is it
when a woman can't pay for her child she
gets government assistant but when a man
cannot pay for his child he goes to jail
or gets his assets he's not in england
though
they get you get your assets seized in
england and then they get assets yes
that's because most men that have no
assets to get seized that's why they get
most men with assets don't get the acid
seized because they become fathers i
don't know i've i've talked to a couple
guys like interviewing on the streets
where yeah yeah like i said that
normally happens most successful man not
just right like the whole lifestyle i i
understand but you're kind of not
answering the question it's just because
of gender roles it's because men are
inherently
seen and we are supposed to be the
providers women are the nurturers
and as much as a feminist world we live
in they still in some so somewhat way
except gender roles
men are providers
so women are seen as the the weaker sex
the government the government knows that
they can uh there's more money to be had
of men than women yeah because men make
up the workforce so if men wake up the
workforce they're contributing the most
to society taxation wise and it's always
a given this is it's always going to be
like that
i i don't complain about it i just think
it's unfair whatever throw caveat in
there and say between the ages of i
think it's 18 was it 18 or 21 between
the age of 21 to 30 women and men yeah
yeah probably that like it goes back to
my point most men get into their peak
potential earning in their mid-30s yeah
then why has it been more conducive that
government focus on men when at a
certain proportion of time women
actually are earned because women
because because women are bad with money
one makes 70 to 80 percent of consumer
buying decisions we hold two-thirds of
the world to debt even though we make
more money we have less because from a
government standpoint that's a good
thing no
from a government's what do you mean
hasn't spent expenditure-wise they're
more likely to make money off people you
spend money more recklessly right but
they're more likely to be in debt
yeah so when you're using like taxpayer
money
like like you have more money to go off
of yeah you have more that makes sense
it's a backwards system clearly because
what you said what you stated is true
and
it's it's just that we have to accept
it's a backward system and we just hope
justice for men you know fathers can one
day put it right i don't think it will
happen i just think i just think men
need to fix up see i don't see i don't
think it's a problem i think the problem
comes from where
women try to strive for equality yeah so
it goes back to the double standards i
will take the double standards that
benefit me yeah and discard the rest
yeah because in a situation
i don't mind being a breadwinner i don't
mind having that responsibility likewise
that's what it's pushing me for step up
if you're pushing for equality then you
can't have that say no more that don't
make sense
no it's so good if a woman goes to work
and owns money so i'm very happy with
that believe me you go earn 50 of
household income combine that's hundred
grand a year we are happy content we can
do that from home however however when
you're trying to be a man
don't be
just just don't try to be a man because
when
man will always protect you you will not
protect the man regardless in any
violent confrontations in life ain't no
female is going to protect the man but
do you think it's a side effect
do you think it's a side effect of women
earning
as much as men that they now think that
they're equal
with men no people brainwashing people
we are two different creatures you have
biological hardware but to male is
different and what industries do women
really out earn men in
what corn
modeling
already like what what what what
industries do women out earn men and
that have to do with that
stop stop
that what what industries do women out
earn men in that don't have to do with
health and beauty
yeah exactly sexualize only the
industries that sexualize their women
i don't think that's the women's fault i
think it's the fact that men have been
in power for so long in such high
positions in these roles they find it
harder to give it to women and that's a
societal issue no women don't want to
know women women women women don't want
to do it women don't want to do those
jobs
do you want to work on all right so so
an oral right yeah yeah it's a
high-paying job on all right yeah i
personally don't want to do that do you
think women generally want to do it but
there's lots of high-paying jobs that
women do want to do that it's harder for
them to get to like i said do you think
women generally want to work on in do
you think women generally want to work
in the industries that are high paying
high hours high stress
and high tension do you think that's the
type of jobs women generally want to do
i'm literally training to be a doctor
high
high money high stress
all of that right but you're you're not
a doctor yet but i'm sorry i understand
you're training to be a doctor but
there's a difference between training to
be a doctor and being a doctor and a lot
of times women get to a certain age and
they just see it's not worth it anymore
like i have a cousin and his his wife is
a doctor and she quit that [ __ ] because
she was like screw this i want to go be
home with my children and i think women
get to a certain age they just want to
be with their kids i don't think it's
society i don't think it's a power thing
i just think they say screw this and
make enough money that's true i think
this does the the book affluenza where
they dictate where they documented it
where they were looking at female
lawyers and say that in terms of the law
profession women actually better it than
men but the women will hit at the age
around age 30 and just quit yeah and
they'll try to retain these women they
just don't want to do it normally having
babies in that that's what they want i
remember there's a there was a beauty
queen in america this year um miss i
think she was miss america or something
like that
she very beautiful
um went to the highest accolade of a law
profession in american can give
got to i think she got to 30 was single
and she all of a sudden quit a law
degree but the reason why she stood out
is because she she ended up committing
suicide
and
i think she had a memoir or something
like that i'm not too sure but it was
supposedly due to the stress of
trying to obtain this uh
law degree and finally getting there and
quitting because her father was a lawyer
stepfather was a lawyer so
i'm not saying it contributed solely
build the pressure she couldn't deal
with the pressure it contributed i don't
know i don't know if it contributes
solely to her demise but in so so
somewhat way she
it was a metrics that she was trying to
reach out to i don't think ultimately
women find real happiness in these kind
of jobs i think women find happiness in
family
kids
children because when they reach a
certain age they don't want to do it no
more well and
and we pick and we pick jobs that make
less money so like men men are 23 more
times more likely to die in the
workplace than women we don't talk about
that inequality but we just want the
pretty positions at the top and say oh
we want to make as much money but we
don't want to do the things to get there
like my dad was a top half a percent
earner he worked 70 to 80 hours a week
for 30 years i don't want to do that
most women don't want to do that and how
would you do that and have kids and a
family it just doesn't make sense sorry
go ahead um oh you know you just
mentioned that you're
you
hopefully become a doctor that'd be
great for you honestly and when you
become a doctor the job consists of a
high intensity high pressure a lot of
hours
it's 70 80 hours a week right yeah yeah
i'm on placement at the moment okay but
you will never die at work
actually your doctors have one of the
highest suicide rates yeah you can you
can kill yourself if you want but can
you wait please don't
don't listen
we're not we're not like condoning
suicide you you will not die because
you're a doctor your patient might
because of your malpractice but on oil
rig you will die if you're not careful
do you understand your mistake patient
dies my mistake in ulrich i die people
around me die every day
that's that's a massive difference
between men's jobs and females jobs we
tend to lot we love putting our lives on
the line we love doing some dumb mad
mental ninja stuff and we will do it
and we love it we love we love getting
battered we love getting shorter we love
it that's one man the army yeah i get
him
call of duty
most most medics in the army are females
they don't have weapons
they don't want a weapon they're not
allowed to have weapons in general
medics but they don't die medics don't
die
soldiers die they're most men honestly
i'm just letting you know that it's like
most females jobs females don't tend to
die at work they just don't diet but if
they're choosing to die that's their own
choice at work if they want to do a
risky job that's their choice i
understand i don't get what the point is
the whole the whole the whole yeah the
whole point is that men build the world
we could not function without men men
allow us to have the jobs that we have
if men didn't do the job that they do we
couldn't even work at all men build the
world but can barely run it have you
seen most countries are run by that's
okay
actually okay one of the best-run
countries in this run did you know did
you know that women are more likely to
wage war than men
if they're in power they are more likely
to wage war um where's that from like
that statistic you could you could
google it if you google it but it has
but have women
because evidently they don't have wages
yes more men are in power
so
so okay okay yeah so more men are in
power and have been in power throughout
all of history and a lot of times we'll
look at that and say oh it's because
they're oppressing women i'm sorry
people get shot when they're in power
people were assassinated like a lot of
people didn't want to be in that
position because it came with a lot of
responsibility and you had a target on
your back
and when women were in that position
they were more likely to rage war they
raged war at a higher rate
do you know why men make better at
building societies
um because you're saying that you know
female-led societies because they're
fathers right and they understand what
it is to protect society so when you go
into societies you will find
the sewer people that are in the sewers
the plumbers the mechanics the people
that run the infrastructure of the world
are men a lot of them are fathers
because they're doing this because they
understand that they're building a
legacy not only that they build a legacy
they're building a nation
for their child at least or maybe their
or maybe their their wife or their woman
so when you say things like
women you know a better running
societies and stuff it's just like well
it's the men that run and build the
infrastructure societies they always
have done women don't want to do it
maybe they're building the
infrastructure but think about who runs
the countries who runs who who was
running our country boris johnson look
not where the western world should be do
you get what i'm saying we have the
highest we are
let me let me just cut you like we have
the highest standard of living in all of
human history ever we're in a living
crisis okay i understand i understand
that
i understand that we also have one of
the highest rates of depression i i i i
don't necessarily think that's true i i
just can't imagine during the plague
that they're happier
right now okay
i understand but i'm saying like
comparatively you're making a statement
and i'm saying i i it could be true but
if you ask people during the plague are
you happy right now i just can't imagine
it was
are you putting that down to men the
reason why people are so unhappy is that
what you're doing or male leaders no but
i'm saying the state of the country so
let's look at our country right now
we're in a living crisis depression
rates are going to go up suicide rates
are going to go up we saw this in the
last recession we had that was the
highest rate of suicide and you can
check the statistics for this that was
like for years and years and years
because we went into a recession which
was led by lockdown
lockdown wasn't was another reason why
depression rates only shot up in 2019
and 2018 um and also suicide rates shot
up if you look at the graph it goes down
down down
but yeah and all the policies are put in
place things that are put in place the
way this country is going the living
crisis was due to men that were
incompetent i'm not saying all men i'm
saying incompetent man
everyone can run things better if women
were more competent why didn't they do
it
if women if women were better at it why
aren't they in those positions there's
nothing stopping them there is a lot of
things stopping them the whole thing is
that society's stopping them
also doesn't want women even everyone
here saying women can't run things
that's not people that are going to vote
for women to be president
again that's not true because more women
vote than men
they're women make up the majority
majority of votes there are more women
on the planet than men
in the uk are you saying everyone
everywhere nobody in the uk and the u.s
correct yes
so so this like oh we can't run because
people won't vote for us but there's
more women voting
so we even we even recognize ourselves
that women don't make the best leaders
yeah i'd like to know what you think a
woman would do differently if she was in
a position of power but we we already
have that example remember
um the german prime minister um
margaret thatcher margaret thatcher look
liz truss let's see what she's doing
yeah um
angela mark
what do you think women would do
differently from men why they would make
better leaders
wait can i just answer the question
first i feel like you'll give an example
of conservatives so it's like i wouldn't
think a conservative would be a great
leader anyway
a conservative woman yeah so you give us
examples of like theresa may and stuff
like that like so you have to get a
liberal woman
no i just i just don't think
conservatives is the best way for this
class okay so i want to get into
politics no no we're just talking about
men and women so what do you think is do
you think a liberal woman do better in
wait so conservative women don't count
not i think she means by the party
affiliation do you mean by the
do you want a labor you want a labour
party woman running a country yeah okay
so even a labor party right so i'm
asking so what would she do differently
what would she do differently
politically or what would a woman do
differently because i think if we look
at new zealand as a prime example they
have like one of the best responses to a
lot of things terrorism happens in a lot
of countries when it happens in the uk
they don't do really anything like they
do things about it it's always too late
we always get a terrorist attack
something will happen in new zealand the
first time they had like an instance of
a terrorist that was just they went to
trial with him straight away they do
things way quicker this was on the news
it was a massive thing that was going on
and everyone was praising the the leader
of new zealand was she conservative or
labor role
i think she's about she's a labor
government is she still in power now
so
so according to your logic you're saying
if we're going to get a female leader we
have to get a labour female leader not a
conservative one because they'll do a
bad job so when we get a terrorist
account terrorists
you seem to have a lot of pent up anger
towards men
i'm not angry i'm never saying all men
i'm saying certain men like i i feel
like if jeremy corbyn was running this
the country would be unique
what if we did that with race do you
think people would feel this type of way
about it
if you said like a certain race so if
you said not all of this race but a lot
of this race doesn't run the country
well
race enters like an ethical background
i'm talking about a gender matter yeah
yeah but i'm saying like i'm saying i'm
wondering why is one okay but one isn't
it seems like
you're talking about political
affiliation
because power's a conservative woman i
think she'd run the country great
i'm just saying i'm not voting for her
with her ideals i've heard her ideals
i've heard what she thinks society i've
heard the way she thinks about
relationships and the course structure
it vote for me yeah i'd vote for you
right
the core structural society when it
comes to family nuclear family keeping
it together i think it's great look what
canada does how canada's handling it
though like they're just they're further
destroying the the nuclear family
they're they're encouraging uh i don't
know if i can say the word but like you
know
people that like to mess with kids
like uh they're giving little kids um
puberty blockers right they're
they're essentially castrating the
little kids
and
these kids they they can they don't have
their
the they can't
you know have sex because they can't
they can't they can't consent to sex
right because they're too young but
somehow they can consent to having their
gender changed
something don't add up here yeah i think
you know but you know what that is sorry
to cut you do you know what that is
that is down to mothers yeah i was just
about to say that so down to fathers
this this whole example of women leaders
there's a common trend of of women
leaders in history it even dates back to
the bible times
uh esther in the bible came into
province promises power when there was
a terrible time
in history so
you see we have we have examples of uh
mercury in germany germany has recently
come out of a bad history
i'm sure we all know
it doesn't speak to me that a woman can
do the job there it just says that the
masculine men are not fulfilling their
roles that they should you know there's
not enough men you know what would
happen if women are in power they'd be
like oh i'm not talking to that country
because she did that
she didn't come to my birthday she said
something about my shoes i didn't like
my feelings
you know you know how we know whether
we're in a patriarchy or a matriarchy
it's by
who do we cater to more
um
yeah who on who who do you think
understands the under other gender more
do men understand women or do women
understand men um can i just say
something so i feel like with my answers
before i was saying that like women can
run the same role whereas everyone in
this room was saying no men can't
women can't do the roles that men do
only men can do those roles so i feel
like everyone no yeah that's not what
we're saying i feel like it was i can
clarify because everyone was saying that
because a woman can't do that a woman
can't do that that's a mantra a woman
doesn't want to be doing that i'm saying
women don't want to they don't choose to
because there's no law stopping us from
doing it and we don't choose them that's
very different than saying we can't
women are choosing them no they don't
know they aren't so if you go to the
scandinavian countries right
scandinavian countries the most
egalitarian countries that are on the
planet right where men and women are
more equal they've done these studies
they said men and women are more equal
you have the right to choose exactly
what you want to choose do you know what
happened they became more divided
because the men went to certain
industries and women went to certain
industries men went to the stem fields
science science technology engineering
and mathematics women went to healthcare
social care stuff like that babies just
having a baby so so so even when women
get the chance to do the same things
that men can do
they don't do it goes back to nature you
heard with what's happening in the
scandinavian countries right like um
they've they're banning men
for bringing um asian wives because the
women they don't like it
they don't want to date them anymore
like it's actually actually banned like
shout out y'all the whole like the whole
like
thai community is is in uproar because
they have like they they can travel
there but they're not allowed in that
specific country because is that because
the women of what they don't like their
own marriage because men men don't want
to date them they they rather go into
these other countries women are more
feminine wasn't the tender swindler
doing the scandinavian countries right
yeah
it's like prime prime material for
scamming
like
you know like yeah
um okay so i have a question
going back to like the father's thing
why is it when would you guys agree that
if a father abandoned his child he's a
deadbeat
this is incompetent man yeah like yeah
just yes or no yes yeah yeah just like
overall okay
why is it when a woman aborts her child
they call it her
choice that's that's a living modern day
double standard because she's just as
bad she's worse in my eyes
i mean i've got my opinion on that but
yeah my body my choice isn't it yeah
yeah but why she's supporting it but all
based on circumstances
well i mean forty percent of women that
have had abortions have had two or more
so i can't seems like it's a pattern at
some point what if the woman doesn't
want the man around
i i feel that like i feel like i
shouldn't i shouldn't have to pay if you
don't want me around the kid
fair enough don't don't don't make me
pay for it then
if you want a kid without a father and
you don't want me around
like why am i responsible for anything
and
and if if i have to be responsible
i want to have equal
equal access to the child right yeah
it's just like the example of my my
friend i said previously he
didn't want it she did
she went along with it had it
and in the night he tried to deny his
access financially to it only for her to
leave the country and come back and try
claim of him now he wanted to be
involved
wasn't allowed not because he not
because of any other reason other than
the poisoning of the mother to the child
and now the child because he's at
liberty to speak to the child but the
child doesn't want her do you know what
that is
you see because men will act actions we
will
react straight away but females are
vengeful they'll remember so she's doing
this so he squeals are you saying are
you saying are you saying we hold
grudges 100 percent she did this so he
feels
insignificant at being a man she knows
how he feels and she knows it and she's
doing on purpose she's watching him cry
inside and she's happy that's evil so do
you think mothers get too much power
when it comes to children
100
no no no mothers
should have that power i feel that
fathers don't get enough power
because we want to be equal
so
we don't need to remove
rights from a certain
from a certain gender
to have equal rights we need we just
need to give
more rights to the opposite one like we
need to eliminate double standards but
we can only do that together women have
to be on board with this if women say i
don't need a man and they have a kid
does that imply that the kid doesn't
need a father
essentially essentially yeah in their
mind essentially i mean it
the stats don't add up not only that
biologically you don't know it don't
make sense
you have a masculine and feminine role
for a reason
would you say that
by that we can say that single mothers
are selfish and they're going to die
alone
he
i feel like you're saying single mothers
but you've got to understand why the
woman is single in the first place if
the man has decided to leave that was
his choice no that's not true men don't
leave women women leave seventy to
eighty percent of the time ninety
percent of their colleagues
is it due to the men's actions to why
they're black
foreign and so there's some recent
studies that say that women cheat more
but is that the reason why the women are
leaving these men no but like you know
what's funny though why is it in this in
this situation you're asking why but
when the man leaves no one asks why
people do ask why the man leaves why is
the man leaving um they're less likely
to watch i mean when i just asked
everyone is it a dead beat nobody said
one yeah they're more likely to say
no wait i didn't i didn't agree with
that wait i agree with a statement but
the same way if a mom leaves she's also
a deadbeat because why are you not
looking after your kid you if you've
taken the responsibility to get someone
pregnant have a child and bring that
child to full time where it's going to
be delivered both of you should be
having that responsibility to now raise
that child that is your individual
responsibility to take because they
don't believe they're bought listen to
what you said both of them have to have
their responsibilities so if the mother
leaves or the father leaves somehow
they're both at fault but they're not
they're not leaving they report him oh
wait they're
in total i feel like but that's
different because with an abortion
and if the mother chooses pro-choice she
wants to get rid of the the fetus it's
not it's it's not it's not doesn't
have a
it's not viable on its own essentially
it hasn't been born it hasn't been
birthed it's not viable it actually it
actually is in the uk so in the end
yeah in the uk it's legal up to six
months and there are some there are some
babies that have survived survived
around five i have a solution so you
know
so you don't think that
it's a child or it's actually a human
being before 24 weeks you don't think
that's a human being it's it's not a
human being before 24 weeks what if you
decide to leave a child that's an that's
a whole formed entity that can exist on
its own do you know what i'm saying
children can't exist on their own for
for a woman to have an abortion
pro-choice it's her body right she's
she's then choosing to change her whole
body whatever whatever happened
like she's gonna have to go through all
those changes of her body it's her
choice whether she wants to go through
that or not that that fetus doesn't have
feelings it can't think of anything
until okay until it's viable of course
24 weeks
and abortion changes your body too
like you can make it so you don't have
kids later yeah but that's if you have
it depends but that's one of the risks
of abortion it doesn't happen with every
single abortion that's a right where do
you think the life cycle starts yeah
that's what i wouldn't know yeah where
do you think the life cycle starts at
what point yeah well i'm muslim so 120
days
so your life cycle only starts at 120
days
for
the cycle of life
so before when do i know 120 days while
it's like from conception
so it doesn't start as soon as sperm
hits egg that's not when a life cycle
starts for you no that's like a cell
it's like a cell that you can pick up
it's not i said life
it actually has a unique dna code that's
different from the mother and the
fathers and
98 of biologists say that life begins at
conception but if we're going to believe
like the science you know they say life
begins that comes conception right but
it's not it's not in it's not
wait who says life begins 90 of
biologists 90 percent of biologists say
that life begins at conception yeah like
if they found um like if they found
a unique dna code on mars like everyone
would be freaking out like wow that's
crazy
i have a solution for this
if uh
fair enough you wanna you wanna abort
the child
your body your choice
but if the man doesn't wanna abort the
child doesn't want you to board the
child i feel like you should still have
the right to do so
but you need to give the father a payout
you need to buy them out
i just think abortion should have two
people's signature on a piece of paper
saying that we both choose to abort this
child yeah
that's what that's what i personally
believe i believe that if not if i i'd
believe that it's not just a mother's
choice because like i said the father
started that life cycle too so he should
have a say and the only way our child
should be avoided if
is if both parents agree to it i don't
think the woman having all of the soul
power over
uh the child which is a man's that
you're going to as soon as it comes out
to him saying look this is yours child
support
like he doesn't it's like he doesn't
have any rights
until that child leaves your womb and
then as soon as he leaves your womb the
woman has the power to just
control that man's life i don't i don't
think that's fair
as a man if you're if you're killing my
child
like i need a payout for that
you know like how much would the payout
be for elections roughly how much is a
is a human life i mean worth a thousand
two thousand okay oh my god no i'm
asking you what the power is
i'm asking you what the payout is
if you're gonna okay okay maybe can you
not do that like it's fine the
government does the government puts
because that's how insurance is working
oh a hundred thousand yeah hundred
thousand upwards like it has to be an
astronomical amount so that would that
would stop women from getting abortions
i have a question so you're saying
life's so valuable and women should not
be allowed to abort it but it's
negligible when it comes to money
involved no no i'm saying women should
be alive because you can't force a woman
to do something that they don't want to
do with their body but you have to not
you have to take into account the fact
that the man also has an investment
there emotional
they sacrifice as well as women you know
if not not with their body but with
their with their mental health with
their
like
with
like they provide and whatever
like
imagine 18 years of providing for a
child right
if the the man doesn't want to have a
kid
like
who's paying
the man
for those 18 years where he lost a child
that he could have had
how how does the how does the man
get
you know
that's heartbreaking
it depends what type of man you are
really
some men have no emotions because they
were raised with no emotions
so if they get a woman pregnant she did
this here like have a good day thank you
very much please what reproductive
rights do men have
zero
i feel like
well i don't know maybe you guys can
answer this i feel like a lot of the
time when a girl gets pregnant and it's
because a lot of guys are get
accidentally get their situation ships
pregnant they'll say to the girl can you
get an abortion i don't want this or
they'll be cheating on their wife and
get an abortion all of those things so i
feel like you're saying it's it's it's
not it's not fair that oh that a woman
can get an abortion but when i feel like
in the uk the majority of the time it's
the man that wants to have an abortion
so how is it an accident when women know
when we're ovulating and women can
choose whether or not to be on birth
control most women don't know when
they're ovulating because most women
don't have trackers and they're not
always reliable but wouldn't that put
the power in women's hand like you can
get an iud that's 99 effective you can
take a plan b
you can get the do the pills you can do
the thing in your arm but that's all
things that modify your body they're all
adding hormones a lot of people get
really bad side effects from from using
those
you can you can you can require that the
men that you sleep with wear a condom
mm-hmm that could be a request the man
should also be wearing
no no
but i'm saying like like women have all
the power in this situation and if it
doesn't all doesn't work out we can go
get an abortion so what reproductive
rights do men have
using a condom that that's it that's not
right so so i'm saying it's not even
it's not equal so did you listen to how
many things pearl listed and how many
and how many reasons you had as to why
that wasn't viable so it's like you've
got the iud no i don't want that
hormones okay so you've got um
what 41 types of birth control they're
all the same thing in different forms
basically so you've got 41 ways then you
have then
then you have the hormones on the copper
one then you have the morning after pill
right
and
then
you have the right after
negating all of those things to just say
to the guy
child support time but when they came
out when they were doing new um like
they're doing research at the moment for
male contraception that included like a
tablet and also a gel a lot of men like
if you went to social media and looked
at the post men were like i'm not taking
tablets imagine a girl tells me to take
my birth control the same way that you
did the same way you just did when we
brought up birth control
like the same way the same way
side effects we haven't spoken about the
side effects but they were taking them
out girls don't take out of it but but
i'm saying like i just brought this up
now and your first response was but the
side effects so kind of the same way but
we don't know the side effects of the
men's one we haven't yeah we don't even
know if it's a hormone thing or whatever
okay but
you see the double st like you just did
the same thing let's say i'll do it i
genuinely don't see it let's say i'll
take the pill i'll take the pill
you're barely
willing to deal with my bs just as it is
would you be able to deal with my bs if
my hormones were not a wacky
you be a woman mate
this just goes down to a pure lack of
accountability
i think
women should be more aware if if they're
not already that they are the
gatekeepers of every single child
vast majority of the time for the very
few exceptions i'm not going to mention
for the algorithm
they are the gatekeepers for every child
they bear
so this just goes down purely to
accountability of who the men they are
choosing and the foundation that they
want to bring a child into this world
the reason why we live in this society
is because women are refusing to take
accountability feminism is on the rise
and marriage is on the decline if every
woman bound together and said we are not
having sex unless you get married what
do you think men are going to do
they are going to the shop to get a ring
they are the gatekeepers of sex they are
the gatekeepers of children to bear in
this society so we can talk as much and
make as many excuses to kingdom come
unless women take accountability for the
mistakes that do happen it's not going
to change but marriage isn't even the
way forward anymore because women leave
we make women leave they do leave them
but again that i've got my own view on
marriage i'm i am myself but i i would
always advocate when it comes speaking
on the subject of father
of fatherhood for men to get their stuff
together men have to get their stuff
together to be the type of one because
hypergamy's on the rise
so hypergame is normally on the rise
it's on the rise
women want
the criteria
right now
the criteria for man is getting less and
less and less this is this is this is
the reason why women refuse to settle
you get a woman in her 40s she could
have settled in her 20s but she's
looking for superman and clark kent at
the same time that man don't exist you
know there's a book there's a stanford
university neurobiologist neuroscientist
called robert sapolsky he wrote two
books there are many but behave and why
zebras don't get ulcers if you read
these books
it will tell you where life starts and
why life starts at conception
it it goes intricate details into dna
neuroscience neurotransmitters the law
look i'm not even neuroscientists are
barely going to education i read this
book because i understand it right it
explains me how to i'm going to treat my
child when he grows up because it talks
to you about child development and male
and female aggressions
it's intricate details about our
existence from scientific perspective
and if you read it is is informative do
you know women are more likely to be
violent towards their children than men
yeah my mom beat me up with time
i can't believe that
yeah i mean
because flashbacks of my mom's straight
away
but you know why because because i i
think that's because
men
with your father they had the threat of
violence and you really have to do it
yeah yeah i remember my dad just looking
at me yeah there is a big difference
between my mom and dad looking at me i
had a flashback there
that
they don't even need to speak to command
respect from children
when my dad when i did something wrong
my mom didn't even need to say so you
just said i'm getting i'm gonna i'm
gonna tell your dad
and me and my brothers fixed up
i remember the first time i ever got
arrested
the beating i received made sure i never
did that again
so
there is an authority figure in a male
that cannot be exchanged for women there
is a way a man raises children with
authority and in love
that cannot be exchanged so
i see why we're like this
i see why society is being like this i
see why women are like this even on the
point of i know i touch a lot on the
boys but i can speak for from a male a
female perspective the first woman
uh the first man a woman learns to love
and submit to is her father he's your
dad yeah so far because he's the only
man who can look at your daughter's eyes
give you everything you want and not
want anything in return he's the only
man who should be who will not take
anything back in return in pure love so
unless you have a good understanding of
how
to love a man and how a man should love
you
you have no blueprint for love so what
do you think monogamy's the way forward
monogamy yeah in my i'm a christian so i
have a
traditional mindset but i also know the
type of men
the type of men men want to be
they might it may not be consistent with
their worldview but for my personal
worldview yeah
in terms of the fabric of society it
starts at home
so i'm interested because obviously you
practice polygamy right
um i'm in a monogamous relationship now
but by nature i am polygamous yeah
could you how would how would it be
raising a child in that type of
environment um would you say
the only reason i can afford to be
polygamous is because
i don't believe in marriage
um
left and right i've seen marriages fall
apart and i don't want to be a part of
it i'm scared of it i'm scared of what i
could lose
um and
because of that and i'm also like the
type of guy that needs a lot of
attention needs a lot of affection one
person it's very hard for one person to
give me all that because they get
suffocated
so i don't think i'm the best example to
to throw in there
but
i do believe that
a proper family
where kids are being raised should be
monogamous
so what about you
uh your point of view or on what
monogamous i think monogamy is the way
forward yeah i grew up in a home where
monogamy i
i've seen society society deteriorate
as marriage breaks down yeah so the less
the more single parent homes there are
the more problems you start to see in
society by and large i've seen it i grew
up in an estate yeah where we all grew
up in the same environment but the only
difference for me in regards to them
was the fact that i had two people then
i didn't because i always had that
deterrent there was always
if this goes a step too far i don't have
to deal with what i've got at home
literally i i got a neighbor i grew up
with won't mention his name but
people who know me will know who exactly
who he is he went down for for murder
uh 25
and
my mom always used to say to me
growing up not to be so close to him
because she my mom was older in
hindsight i see exactly what she she was
talking about her mom used to have
different men come around
her dad his dad was never around and
there is
and he was always the sort of guy that i
in some somewhat way used to follow
until my dad stepped in and removed me
because
he
the way he used to run live was was
purely based on on society's influence
that ends us you know being coming from
this was she a single mother she was a
single mother
he
kind of ran his own rule around his own
mother and this was what i'm talking
about about 10 when i was at in frisbee
park so
and
fast forward later i think about
must have been about six years ago now
six seven years ago i'm 31 so he's
mid-20s he went down for murder but when
i told my mom this she said i i saw this
coming
it happens a lot i saw this coming which
is like i'll read the stats because you
know i've read them before about 63
percent of suicides
are from children from cinco mother
homes 90 of homelessness and runaway
children are from single mother homes 85
of children with behavior disorders are
from single mother homes 80 of convicted
rapists
are from single mother homes 71 of high
school dropouts are from single mother
homes eighty percent of youths in prison
are from single mother homes
can i just say something um i'm very
blessed man in a lot of ways in terms of
my family like i'm not minted
but i can pay my own rent
so
my mom my my dad never beat my mom on me
and my sister there was no violence at
all
and
in school i had a very bad time in
school in england i came to england i
was 14 so from 14 to 16 my schooling
consisted of
physical verbal and racial abuse from
all people when i was 20 somebody sliced
my throat and tried to kill me i would
sell cracking heroin in this country i
have mom and dad who didn't beat me and
i still so what i'm trying to point out
so there's differences between what i
read in this book that you can expose to
violent environment and still not be
violent or you're being exposed to
violence and that's when you become
violent when your parents expose you to
violence or you don't have no parents or
want to yeah and you live in a vibrant
violent environment are you going to be
part of that violence and you're going
to contribute towards it and then you're
going to get 25 to life at 25.
like i got very lucky i'm alive at 16
years ago somebody sliced my throat and
tried to murder me and i have mom and
dad who didn't even beat me they got
universities degrees i don't even got
that but that's that's a very unique
situation that i'm from how i i came
through the challenges that were
presented to me but if i didn't have a
dad
or a mum or both that like listen are
scared of my mom she i'm scared still
now so i got fortunate and blessed in a
lot of ways and yet my life still had a
lot of violent outcomes
do you guys think that women that get
ivf are selfish
without a husband where they just get in
vitro fertilization and just have a kid
on their own and choose to be a single
mother
no but that does affect the child
you don't think they're selfish why
because i mean
let's say let's say like you're a
lesbian couple
okay okay no no no no no i'm not talking
about lesbian couples i'm talking about
single mothers oh
i think even single mothers can have
people in their lives who's an effective
role model for the child
so i don't think it necessarily means oh
they're selfish and i feel like you
don't think it's selfish to put your kid
at every statistical disadvantage you
possibly could a statistic is a
statistic it doesn't mean it's going to
happen
but if they come around the people with
the if they if they're in a growing and
growing up in a home that's loving they
have good role models around them good
education they're less likely to be part
of that statistic so it depends on what
you're around and what you grow up with
if this is a single mother who's giving
a child the best education the best role
models all of those things they're less
likely to be part of that statistic so
most women who are getting ivf which
they're paying for are going to be ones
that are more well-off that can do that
for their children would you say that
wait so you think because of money
that replaces the dad no no i said
they're more likely to have like these
statistics to do with social economic
profiles as well of single mother
households no i mean you see like like
kids from single mother households go
shoot up a school like it's not
necessarily like you're equating like
men to money
it's got nothing to do with money it's
it's purely based on morals and
principles and the dynamics of a male
and a female we have our roles
and the
the father imputes his masculine role
onto his son and onto his daughter
the daughter grows up in reverence of a
man
in respect and in love and in submission
without that
you can see what's happening in today's
world and to say say women are walking
around so they don't need men and it's
most likely because they've never had a
man to love and not want anything in
return i.e the father
i think it really depends on i think
what any situation you come from the
outcome you decide to have from it
depends on your own motivation there's
boys that have come from homes with
their single families and turned out to
be the most amazing boys
yeah that goes for everything in life
you can have a kid who's grown up in the
worst in the world in really bad poverty
and be one of the top in his school or
you can have a kid that went to private
school and not do anything look i grew
up in from a single mother with five
children
on a council estate in south london
i should have been a statistic
right i should have been
and trust me i was around drugs
i was around violence i was a lot of
people that i know went to prison my
family went to prison
we i grew up in a place you know that
wasn't too good but i turned out like
this i never i haven't been in trouble
the police i haven't been to prison i
haven't been to jail do you know i mean
i'm live my life relatively normal
but i would be the exception to the rule
anomaly
but just because i have this story it
doesn't mean that the statistics that i
read
don't exist
but so i'm acknowledging the fact that
i'm the exception to the rule but i'm
also acknowledging that
the other things exist
in the majority
so
so this is one of the things that people
generally tend to do they change and
even me knowing that i'm the exception i
still don't argue the exception because
i lived on the estate that i lived on
and i saw all the other guys go down the
other route so i knew that i was the
anomaly do you know what i mean so that
exists to me so i could say oh i made it
out but that doesn't mean that that
doesn't exist would you have preferred
to have a father there 100
and and that's like like because to me
if if you're choosing to put your kid in
a situation where you know they're going
to want a dad and they're going to ask
these questions like you're kind of
thinking about what you want over your
kid it's absolutely selfish it's the
fact that they've played the the short
game long
they thought they can
live a life
that's conducive to themselves at that
time and at the end of it still have
their cake in here and what i mean by
that is
a lot of women that end up in that
situation
are are women who are literally
unmarriageable
because the ma the market dictates who
who you take because we men decide how
the sexual dynamic works women decide he
has sex and many decide to remarry so if
these women
as a consequence of the action become
unmarriageable
what they're essentially doing is trying
to have their cake in here by going for
these ivf's and leaving their child at a
statistical disadvantage just because
they wanted to live the life they wanted
without consequence it's most definitely
selfish and there's no question about it
and the way people
are are so brazen in justifying madness
is is stupid to me i mean like i said
fatherlessness we just heard um what was
your name again andy you just heard his
story you know andy's story is a million
men's story do you know i mean
five million men story so for women to
choose not to
um
to to choose to have children without a
father to me he's just very selfish and
not just men women like
i'm i'm pretty sure that over 80
if not the vast majority of strippers
have either no father yeah or
absolutely terrible relationships with
their father and i will go against the
grain and say they have no father
because if they did or have a father at
best brothers
we know as men how we view
how how we how women can be objectified
no man wants that for his loved sister
right no man wants that for his any
woman in his family
so
it makes sense to me as to why these
situations pan out there is a lack of
masculine figure in these people's lives
the the a lot of the women a lot of
women young women these days who are at
the most promiscuous high
are selling themselves short because
they don't know in the long run men are
not going to want them
and not only that they can hide they can
go to a different city because we spoke
we spoke about this previously they can
move
but it goes to show your discipline and
character when you devalue yourself in
such a way
and at the end of it there's going to be
a consequence because the ultimate game
and the ultimate goal for every woman is
to be in a long-term relationship some
so somewhat way marriage or at least a
committed monogamy relationship
the statistics show it and we know it by
biology sense but what they fail to
realize is
the means of getting it
they don't know that it takes just as a
man
i know what it takes to get a girl and
over the years i'm married over the
years i know i've known and i we know
this from the day we're born we have to
become something otherwise you're not
getting recognized
but women don't know what it takes to
obtain a relationship because everything
has been given to them from the
beginning
and then and then we have this you know
this boss [ __ ] mantra where you know we
can we don't men don't want that in buy
and launch and the men who do want it
you don't want them anyway we're going
to get back to this pearl we got to get
to the super chat so i have um some
super chats guys make sure you like the
video the like is the most important
metric that youtube uses to push out
this content so make sure you like the
video we all work hard here so like it's
free come on also all of these um all
these super chats are going towards a
new camera um we want to get blessing
you want to shoot him what is it 8k
you got to say to the mic
they can't hear you they can't hear
you all right
all right he said 8k
8k
um okay so
90 free top pro choice huh would you
okay with women aborting their babies
based on race discount um ariana grande
beauty is not worth it usa usa usa big
breezy also scientific studies show that
fetuses have a type of consciousness
around at three months and they can
perceive pain around that time too
sentience um to the haram ho i heard you
are considering a future in medicine if
you come debate with the facts and
self-educating that that barely
foreshadows your level of commitment to
the profession i'm proud of you to be in
we don't want you to be lazy and
uneducated people kevin b when someone
passes away why doesn't their body still
have a unique dna sequence big breezy
it's 90 days not 120 days and only for
very specific circumstances grape threat
to the mom's life and even then we
believe it's extremely disliked by god
there's no pro-choice in islam tell the
girl to fix up sentience she's muslim
dressed like that and thinks a growing
fetus is nothing more than a clump of
cells at 24 weeks i call haram she is
more like mia khalifa than a virtuous
woman i wonder what a muslim man what
muslim man would claim that to the haram
ho we do know the effects of male birth
control the most recent one was the most
recent one given resulted in a very high
percentage of sterilization and mood
alteration to the point where one man
died please educate yourself on facts
before commenting on things maury this
is haram her ancestors would be a shame
ike amalio adu completely asked tonight
to think that women leaders should don't
have to pull their strengths you all
leave politics out of gender war the
most divisive topics are used by the
elite to sway your support
90 free topaz donald donald trump is the
goat respect his name um where can we
call in pearl i'll teach her about dt
the poor dad anyone mad hard crushing on
pearl alistar horton if women make
better leaders um why has every woman
only
if women make better leaders why has
every women-only civilization died off
90 free tope most euro places are
failing under women governance big
breezy i think he'll more likely
i think he'll be more likely to move
past the pain if he speaks to his dad
and speaks to him on a level as he's
tried to reach out grudges are taxing
red cowa i was scared of my father who
who was a cold man but as an adult i
find he gave my mother everything while
she poisoned me against him she made me
think he was a monster and that i was
too for being a man she'll deny it but
that's the truth tan lady sounds just
like her ben garrig um in the socks hat
did you meet your dad or are you going
to go by what your mom told you many
moms lie i know from experience how
cheryl l hey pearly dear maid of
my okay hey pearly my dear maid of the
internet someone to humble these hoes a
match for you would be michael rosenbaum
type um
a small bill's lex luthor gloria starr
is a maid made to internet too ish is a
bouncer of the internet because it's
real out here in the inter interwebs
ship advice real femme sapien ali is a
matchmaker her ships are archetypes
school teacher the brain art competitive
business savvy she's also material plus
cooking cool aunties warrior medic
school teacher and she's a legalist he's
material rebecca
barrett's ship law in keeper poet nature
real from sapien can spot soulmates a
mile away yes daddy's simping but we
still have beef fam beef tm pending ps
just helper administrator fashion foodie
wedding planner much steve harvey's a
max matchmaker
k mall young lady in the top everyone
has dreams and aspirations growing up
means being pragmatic about a balance of
the two it's all right it will come to
you life will teach you jc how about
instead women can and men can be um
numbers guys zero i love you pearl i
just wish your push back to two easily
objectible argument sounded less
agreeable maury i got girls like this in
my dms every day
a mr bombie nuke um to the blue baggins
super chat she hurt herself from these
poor decision and can't accept the coats
and denial hi pearl thanks for the show
blue baggins to the pretty girl in the
gucci belt who hurt you rick riches um
married with no ring huh um let me
refresh it really quick and just see if
there's any more again i'm just reading
these these are not
um okay 90 free toe pay pro choice huh
oh wait i did that one okay
has been paying a lot
okay guys make sure you like the video
also um all super chats are going
towards blessings new camera so we
really appreciate all the super chats
and we will read them one more time
during the show cool i want to kind of
switch to a thing that um isn't spoken
about that much when it comes to fathers
um
have you guys had a parental alienation
so parental alienation is when
a mother
or a parent sorry
forcibly
alienates the child
from the parent
and
willingly and you know purposely turns
that child against um
their other parent and i think a lot of
the times like the chat was saying um
a lot of the time we don't get the other
parents side of the story okay and then
we grow up and then we hear that side
and in my in my experience
i have
three people in my life three men in my
life who were fathers who all went
through
parental alienation
um do you know anybody who has actually
been
alienated from their
from their parent
yeah
yeah
yeah
the guy i was talking about i'm funny
enough him
he's he's been in a situation where he
was uh he's with a girl he's had a child
they were both in a committed
relationship and
for some reason not to my knowledge it
didn't work out
now in frustration of the relationship
they've they're going for a bit of core
battle right now in um trying to obtain
rights to visiting rights and and so
forth
the problem he's facing is the fact that
she's she's not she's not british and
she has by every means
stated that she wants to leave the
country
and
of the mistake of the past because it's
another baby mom
he's not looking to make that same
mistake ever again so
in contrast to um everything he's saying
this is exactly what he's going through
and
fortunately i say fortunate because the
sun is so young um not able to really
understand what's going on
i truly believe that's he's saving grace
because had it been all that it would
have been a lot worse for him due to the
character of the woman
and um from what i understand
he's going through right now
all the lies that's being told against
him which do you think is more likely to
alienate the child female 100 percent
evil yeah 100
because i think it's because it goes to
the fact that
resentment could be held in a different
way from women than it can be for men
and
women know physically they can't hurt
they can't hear a man well they can but
they can't overcome a man with strength
so the way they get at him is an
emotional way and ways that
they possibly may not be able to control
external factors
assets possession
divorce
children
these are external factors from a
relationship that happened and
it seems like
in order to get the get back for any you
know resentment a woman may have for a
child is always
coming out in external factors such as a
child
and most of the time what do we do when
that happens to us to men we kill
ourselves or we kill them
or we just don't do nothing and give all
our money away they walk away from it
they either either just lack the
response walk away from a total
responsibility try to fight for the
responsibility or turn crazy men men are
eight times more likely to kill
themselves after a divorce when they
don't get the kids
yeah
and this is not spoken of and this is
what i was this goes back to my point of
the importance of father these things
ain't spoken of because of the society
the kind of such desire we live in
everything is catered to
feelings
and and not facts or logic
i like to stay on the on the on the side
of logic and fact when it comes to these
things because this is life at hand this
is not this is not something to play
with it's it's life it's
our future generations and future
society so when we play with these
things on emotion that change daily
just to cater to one gender is very
harmful for not just the men the child
in the future
people and and men there's a lot of men
that go broke trying to get their kids
back too and they'll be drained through
like legal fees to the point where they
do sign away their rights but it's not
because they don't want to be in the
kids they just are running out of money
and
and it's like
and then they'll they can go to
especially in the us like you can go to
jail if you don't pay children
but but the government pays women to be
single mothers
so to to answer
the person that um that said like i
might have been alienated by my mother i
understand why you would say that um
most of the time
women do try to alienate their kids from
their mother and uh fortunately for me
it's been quite the opposite my my
mother always kind of encouraged me to
go and meet him
um i've been lucky
from the beginning of my teenage years
i've been lucky that um
my mother found a stepdad for me and uh
he he filled in he filled in the role
quite well but even before that i have
met my father um
and he had the opportunity my mother did
not
you know like limit his access to me he
had the opportunity i told him
like i want you to be in my life but i
was a child i expected him to make the
first move
um and he he just wouldn't
and now to the per to the other person
that said maybe i should meet him no i
shouldn't because
he he
blatantly refused to be to be in my life
and
now that i'm
i'm quite made
um
i find myself that like
i'm
i got to be more successful than
you know
than him i i don't think that i should
suddenly look him out
suddenly make him like
make him proud of me or no he doesn't
deserve that
he had the chance
my mother my mother gave him the chance
my mother encouraged me to give him the
chance
i just wanted him to make the first move
now i understand that you know
my situation is
a bit different like a lot of people
a lot of people's fathers want to be in
their child and to be honest i wish
that
my dad made an effort maybe then
not maybe surely then i would have i
would have totally
you know hung out with him bonded with
him it just didn't happen do you know
what listening to you um
and the way in which you're speaking
your father um
mirrors my life a little bit so it's
very like airy to hear you
speak like that because
i can safely say that i've only ever
hated one person on this planet
and that was my father oh i don't hate
him no i'm not saying you do but i'm
saying the way in which you speak and
like that resentment like he doesn't
deserve it
and i get it you know i get it because
i've definitely been there um
but i would say that when i was like in
my 20s i had all the resentment for this
man like literally if i saw him on the
street i knew that i would try and get
into a fight with him like that's the
way i didn't um that's the way i didn't
love him and um
just hearing you speak is kind of
it should be like a
a message to mothers and a message to
fathers uh also and a minister to
society to say that fathers are really
needed in this society because you know
they are really
creating a fatherless society creates
broken men when you when you have a kid
like
as a child i don't care that you two
don't get along make it work
make it work it's not about you anymore
it's about it's about
your grandchildren not even me it's
about
you instilling in in me
values
you want your grandchildren to be
my mother
like i now have with my step-step dad
shout out to the step-dad
um now
uh i have a little brother and sister
i i don't want a kid
my my dad
dealt himself out of a grandchild
and um would you say that would you say
that's because of your experience with
your dad
there's a multiple factors here like uh
the social the social standards also
have a factor in it like i don't want to
i'm not in a position to have a child
not emotionally not financially
not socially
um it's not worth it for me
and maybe it's gonna be worth it for my
little brother or my little sister if we
make all the
all the necessary changes now to bring
families together
maybe then it's going to be worth it for
them
but i feel that
i've i've missed my chance
i don't want to be
to bring a child
when
i don't know
what's the best way to raise that child
because
i don't have a good example
you know when you you become one
nobody knows how to be fathers but
you think my dad knew he fall in you
do you know how hard it is to raise me i
need to die twice
wonder what he didn't beat me
you'd know when you know you'd not any
answers come on if you have good
intentions in life you're a good person
you love you ever been loved before you
tend to love someone you will end up
loving someone you it's just normal this
isn't almost people that want to be
fathers they're going to be fathers and
they'll love their children
if somebody don't want to they're not
going to and then then the ones that are
going to be neglected guess what they're
going to do grow up when they're 20 25.
what about the dead 12 that my son goes
to school with a child that hasn't got
no father and that child starts beating
my son up what do i do then do i beat
that child up
can i find this father to talk to him i
can't what do i do my child becomes a
victim and then when it's 15 16 it kills
my son what then things like that happen
to people all the time just for general
neglect of children yes there's a
variety of consequences how can i bring
a child knowing that like i can't do
anything about something like that
happening
but you know it's kind of admirable for
him to admit
he's not in the best position to to to
bring a child in the world because a lot
of people just
just think with their dicks and then end
up producing children that they can't so
if he if he has enough self-reflection
and a cognitive mind to know he's not in
the best position to bring a child in
the world
i respect that more than a man who has
absolutely no resources to give a child
and brings it into the world
so i don't think when it comes to
children it's much to do with love
because it's more to do with duty
because love fades
believe me
what i'm trying to say is
[Laughter]
do you have a relationship with your
father me
yeah the best relationship with my dad's
i think he's like the most amazing man
in the world
so i just always had a really loving
relationship with my dad anything i
wanted i got it i just know like
anything if anything happened he'd
always be there to protect me
but i think i've realized in age that a
lot of men that don't come from
homes where they've had like a stable
father or um because they didn't have a
stable father and their mother was
single so she was like busy paying the
bills working they didn't have a father
around they find it a lot more difficult
to love in life
and then i think as someone who's grown
up with really loving parents trying to
get love from a man who didn't grow up
with love is a very hard thing to do and
it's probably not going to work out as
well unless that man has taken a bit
taken gone through an experience that's
made him know because i feel like
someone who hasn't received love doesn't
know how to give love as well as someone
that has received love their whole life
so i think it impacts relationships as
well so you're saying that you had a
good relationship with your father
so what happened
how did you choose those toxic men he's
saying like yeah like like how how did
you end up having these sort of feelings
towards women women like red flags yeah
like she's young
she's 24 years old
i feel like so earlier you were talking
about why you think girls would go for
men that have
um a lot of um power and money and all
this thing the perceived power yeah so
and i actually have a really different
theory to you so i feel like your theory
was
saying that women go for men with
perceived power and stuff but i feel
like if that was true women would go
more for like entrepreneurs and stuff
but they don't the red flags we go for
more like drug dealers um like criminals
things like men that can typically
protect us in society and i feel the
reason we go through that is i don't
know like maybe you guys don't
understand this but the majority of
females have been essayed in some way or
they're scared to go out at nighttime or
they carry their keys in their hand so
the way the majority
wait that doesn't mean that doesn't mean
like to the extreme but it is a
statistic that a lot of women if you
still have feel scared by men okay but
if you're gonna if you're gonna say
words and they're not true i have to
like call you out wait i'm sure there's
statistics on that majority so
okay but not not the scared one you said
the majority have been sexually
assaulted yeah that doesn't and so and
so i know what stat you're talking about
and it's the two out of three women have
been sexual like i i know what statute
is and it's not true they
they they include things like if you're
drunk having sex you've been sexually
assaulted but a lot of women don't also
report this things that i've gone
through from my experience as women i
know a lot of girls that and majority of
my friends that have some form of right
that say that but but how do i know
you're telling the truth it's just your
word against his and you don't know you
don't know the other side so you can't
just believe people are we talking about
convictions yeah no no i'm not so so to
me if i if i was sexually assaulted i'd
go to the police why why wouldn't you
report it that doesn't make sense to me
why would you go around telling everyone
and not go to the police i have a girls
come on a podcast and accuse someone of
something and you don't go to the police
that doesn't make sense
yeah i'm back to your point
you are reiterating what i'm saying
because what i'm talking about is a
perceived notion of status and power and
this is what they exude in
in in in the night life in in in society
they it it's not real because it's not
long-lasting and there's no longevity in
it but it's a perceived notion and
number two they're in the same age
bracket when girls when women are young
they tend to want to be with a man
within the same age bracket so i'm
saying these things are normally
obtained by a man in their 30s
mid-30s early 40s this is the average
man we're talking vast majority of men
obtain this
somewhat perception and reality of
stayers fame wealth maybe not the same
part but wealth stayers
in their mid-thirties so when you get in
a young such as a footballer it's given
to him young is given to him too soon
but he's still
a boy he's not matured in society yet
and i know from personal i'm sure a lot
of the men can agree
men take a lot longer to mature
nobody was checking for me at 18.
you know it takes a whole lot a whole
lot longer for a man to mature so
the point i'm making is you're going for
these kind of guys not just you
personally but girls are going for these
kind of guys but these kind of guys are
not taking the shifts because
they're not looking to sell that's the
point and a lot of times those those
traits it's social status like that like
the things you're talking about like
usually those guys are like good talkers
they have social status
because because women like like men that
other women want yeah like um
historically forty percent of women have
reproduced with eighty percent or sorry
forty percent of men have reproduced
where eighty percent of women have
yeah so i wasn't going to disagree with
what you were saying i was just going to
say another that's just another reason
why girls go for a lot of criminals and
people with a lot of red flags because
they do like the idea of having
protection they want a man that's like
untouchable to everyone else but
touchable to them that's why i was like
if i finished off i was going to say
it's quite an immaturity thing and
that's why i feel like when women grow
up they don't want to go for the red
flags anymore it's just because they
haven't grown in themselves to realize
that's not what's really going to
protect them what they really need is a
man in a stable job in
a stable life with
ambition and goal that's what i was
trying to cover no you're right usually
usually when girls are younger they tend
to go after those things but the problem
is like it's kind of like you become
their leftovers after
so like a guy doesn't really want a girl
that's been ran through by all the toxic
guys and like the chads they could they
call them chads and tyrones i don't know
why those names let me flip it on its
head
why don't women protect men
it's physically impossible
no
why don't women protect men from women
like i am
i can deal with men
i i i'm not scared of men i i can go i
can go head to head 1 verses 3 1 verses
4 1 verses 5. i've done it before it
happened i've had to do that to protect
my woman
but
i've never been protected by a woman
against
women like i
am scared of women
i
because
i can't defend myself i'm not allowed to
right
um
in what way you mean physically or
emotionally no no no because
everyone can everyone can talk right i
can i can i can speak for myself but it
happened to me i've got essayed
in this country i've got essayed as a
child by women
no one took me seriously
it it messed me up and i only realized
later in life
um
no one protects me no one protects us
women don't like i've had i i was
walking with a girl and
we were we were kind of like debating on
the street kind of like a bit more
aggressively and i had another
another woman stranger just come at me
and literally throw insults and and the
woman that was there like she knew that
we weren't fighting or anything like
there was nothing going on but she just
stayed silent
it's because of the sisterhood
that's what they call it it's like women
feel the need to protect women i have so
many times when girls in my comment
section will be like
why aren't you on our team it's just
like
i'm like i'm just saying what's true
it's not even just a comment section
we've had it on a podcast had a girl
attacked me
wait um
no no on the screen
no like women when women like this is a
thing
women know
when their girlfriends or
family members are doing bad they're
less likely to
acknowledge it which is why
when you talk about the sisterhood when
a woman breaks away from the herd she
gets called a pikmi
yeah she gets she gets called all of
these derogatory names to try and bring
her back into the sisterhood and shame
her for actually leaving the sisterhood
so yeah the sisterhood is uh is very
real you know it's very real i also tend
to find that when i when when i get with
a girl and be going relationship i tend
to attract more women
they tend to like come out and say
pickup artist i went to a pickup artist
conference where like they would um
teach guys how to get laid basically
it's kind of crazy they paid thousands
of dollars to like fly to one location
have one guy literally teach these men
how to get laid you're right they
sometimes they would wear a wedding ring
because more girls would like talk to
him
and like more like women perfect
pre-selection yeah another fun fact is
that women um the reason i keep saying
like women like red flags it's not just
you to everyone um it's because felons
have 30 more kids than non-felons so
shout out us
shout out
is that because you think that those men
display
hyper aggression and women
they equate hyper aggression to
masculine manual manliness yeah it's the
perception that's just like i said the
perception there's there's a perceived
notion on these type of men
that
women are attracted to the things that
they're scared of in some way i've seen
a girls come up to me when i've just had
a screw face and says
why why you look so angry
kept engaging in conversation trying to
you know figure out where this is going
come to find out that
in the end of it she's asking for my
number so i'm looking at her like
you first came across
scared
and now you're attracted
so
there is a notion there that there's a
lot of truth to it they're scared to
what they're attracted to because the
same thing that can damage them as a
saving that can save them it's the
superman clock
yeah women will initiate fights between
men because it turns them on yeah
you know yeah they like that danger
element yeah
they do now
they do they like that they they want to
see they want to see two men go at it is
that honest
especially especially it's over them
we hate that boxers get no play at all
yeah they just do horrible yeah right
but they but they pretend that that they
don't like it
me yeah they all say oh my god it's so
barbaric
but you know they watched human you'll
go at it and you know they're
vegetarians
you also need to understand that women
aware what can kill them
and it's men so they need men that can
kill other men for them they love that
if you know that i can kill people but
leave me here 46 i'm a john man i'm in
um and if you know that i've killed
people
i mean ted bundy got hoes
he got married in prison and that's what
i mean like it's not it's not like
personal to you it's just like when you
study the female nature and you look and
you look at what girls pick like
yeah we like red flags it just is what
it is we can you can like go to therapy
and like pretend we don't but like we're
still attracted to it i don't think i
don't think you can categorize all women
into that i mean you're right it's not
every single woman ever but like i think
you can say generality is about a gender
without with like in a conversation we
can know obviously it doesn't mean every
single woman yeah well i think generally
but like i said i think it's an
immaturity thing and it's just
i think when a woman grows up to a grown
enough age she's not like that most
women that get married in their 30s at
that point they're not marrying red
green flags they might
they're not marrying red flags they're
marrying green flags so yeah you're
right like but to me it's not because
they don't want those guys it's because
they they need the other guys so it's
not because they don't want the bad boys
it's because they need the good guys if
they want a family and to have kids and
so a lot of times it's like a mating
strategy they'll get a kid off of the
bad boy and then marry the other guy and
he has to take care of it or they'll get
they'll sleep with all the bad boys and
then
find a guy to bail him out with all
their trauma at like 32 31. it's it
makes total sense look lois lane
was attracted to spider-man
but did not superman superman but did
not like clark kent
so
there is an aura of a masculine man that
attracts women whether it's the
physicality whether it's the aggression
but what what sometimes happens or what
what they feel to realize a lot of the
time
for the twos to combined
it takes time for a man
at early stages of the man's life he
could be one or he could be the other
sometimes it happens quicker for men
sometimes it doesn't but they want best
of both
you have to compromise with some men
sometimes if if that's what you're
attracted to or be smart enough to know
that these red flags are not conducive
for a long-term relationship but that's
why women
a lot of women
especially especially modern-day women
get with men who are bad boys and then
try to turn them too yeah yeah and they
don't work they say oh i can try and
turn they don't shake they don't change
they never change right
that's frustrating
news
the drug dealer isn't going to get a
stable job
i mean if they get back to
serve 10 years maybe after that but it's
too late
what are you going to do after 10 years
in penn when you get up personal trainer
[Laughter]
[Music]
avoided prison but you know not everyone
gets lucky like i do i got lucky a lot
of ways life is luck your existence is
lucky you're in 2022 1922 we got we're
just coming back from war
we are lucky in our own unique existence
where we look where we do you know where
i'm from
a mission away 86 i was born over there
you know it's like a unique experience
of my life like look where i am and i've
been so many i've been to africa middle
east and south america north america
i've been around galapagos islands do
you know where that is mission i'm just
letting you know that your whole life is
a unique lucky experience and if you're
gonna just
set examples and criterias for men
prepare to die alone
be just be prepared have that the back
of your mind because those men are going
to come around and just whoa up here but
i wouldn't say so much is down to luck
because you make it sound like it's a
lottery your parents made the decision
because no my decision no no i'm saying
i'm saying with your personal experience
civilized my mom and dad no i hear what
you're saying but what i'm saying is
when you say luck like i'm first-gen i'm
a first-generation nigerian they made a
decision to come
to uh to england for a better life and
due to my mom and dad's hard work they
made for themselves
due to their own choices you know the
come up in this country to contribute to
society in the workforce and so forth
but
i wouldn't say so much is to do with
luck i'd say it's choices that are made
decisions that i made
made the conscious choice not to kill
you when you was a baby
that's luck absolutely that's not that's
do you know how many children died by
their moms and dads
yeah you're right yes
i did not choose my mum and dad i did
not get to pick these two people to
raise me they could have destroyed me do
you know how many people that i know who
mom and dad are heroin addicts like i
grew up with them in this country like
my sister next level i don't know this
guy his mom could have been worse than
my mom and he's still here but he got
lucky too we are lucky to exist in 2022
in england not because our parents made
choices
obviously that's part of it but someone
made choices for them some of them some
that have civilized your mom and dad so
that could raise you to be this moral
glorified men if your mum wants
civilized they won't be coming here mate
we've lived in civilization for years
it's nothing nothing's new under the sun
we haven't lived
do you think human beings are barbaric
by nature barbaric but of course
do you think pacifism wins your stuff
pacifism gets you um neville
chamberlain's screaming we got peace in
europe and not is disseminating babies
pacifism doesn't get you anywhere if
we're not
equipped with weapons that everybody
knows that we will [ __ ] you up if you
come to us they will come to you and
they will [ __ ] you up
anyone on the planet earth right now
tell me a country that is weak and
vulnerable russia ukraine gone taken
gone there's if we are england weak not
no no military no power no money we are
getting run down and get turned over by
anybody on the planet earth believe me
that's been lucky from the beginning of
survival
beginning of mankind to the end if you
don't equip yourself you will get if
you're vulnerable people will exploit
that vulnerability and they will kill
you and take
everything at all times from the
beginning of mankind it has never
changed that's why we have nuclear
weapons after world war ii so nobody can
take anything from anyone do you
understand how safe we are
do you know my my grandparents were born
in 1920s and 30s they were fully grown
adults in world war ii they got lucky
that stalin didn't inseminate my
grandparents that nazis didn't kill them
this is real life scenarios i'm not
joking that there were no nuclear
weapons then we are lucky to survive
certain things we act
i could have died from variety of
diseases going to africa south america
belize brunei middle east i didn't die
from them 100 years ago i am dead no
medical experience no medical technology
we are dead we are pretty much dead
traveling by boat you're getting scurvy
that's not a scurvys lack of vitamin c
do you understand the perceptions of
existence how lucky we are in this
civilization it's enormous it's not as
big you love your passion bro it's
enormous it's enormous and i'm alive i
should have been dead 20 16 years ago
somebody sliced my throat and tried to
murder me and i grabbed the knife bended
the blade and saved my life that was in
luck course he was he cut my [ __ ]
corroded artery how did i not bleed out
lucky that's god's grace babe lucky
lucky life is lucky sorry guys
thank
you i was totally engrossed
i don't even know what to do i don't
know what to say after that
look at my questions god damn cheers to
your courage
yeah that's very true cheers to that
cheers god damn you had me in gross i
was trying to trying to get statistics
and stuff right now
um
when it comes to fatherhood did you know
that most single fathers are divorced
by comparison most single mothers have
never been married
wait say that again most single fathers
are divorced by comparison most single
moms have never been married
oh yeah okay oh wow yeah
so that was
that we show that men
have more think a little bit more when
it comes to children yeah yeah yeah so
you can see who's the privileged group
here
women or women
women are the most privileged group in
society we're bailed out of every bad
decision that we make
every single one
yeah if we're homeless there's women's
shelters
if we get pregnant there's abortion if
we sleep around there's birth control
like i can't think of a bad decision
that women make that we're not built out
of
like i'm so flabbergasted how
how like real you're able to be pearl
like
you know like
people call you pygmies but like you're
just looking at evidence and saying like
calling a spade a spade and like
that's why i watch your
thank
content
how do how um
when it comes to fathers
and
when it comes to child we spoke about um
uh child rights when it comes to fathers
do you think that there's enough support
for fathers single fathers when it comes
to like support
if they're like a single father because
you know women get bailed out there's no
social support
as a society in general we're done
socially we don't encourage people
go on go and be a better father all
right go and go and fix things or just
get back with her the child needs you
you know
go go to work go and get a second job
make more money go and education yeah
it's always it's always that men have to
be more
yeah it's like women are less than ever
asking for more from men than ever
better well the question i was just not
sure this is like what i said women if
women dictate what they want and men
will succumb to what they want these
guys that are bagging like are getting
the girls it's no coincidence they know
what it takes to get girls
and you have to get to a certain level
to be everybody knows that guy who used
to get all the girls in school there was
something about him that men have to
aspire to if they want that kind of life
i think this is why andrew tate blew up
because
men were fixated on his lifestyle he was
very true about how he got to it he's
not saying everyone's going to get to it
but if you want this kind of lifestyle
as a man you have to improve you have to
so are you saying that men just need to
support themselves literally it's the
only way we live in a feminized world
now we're telling men oh it's all right
to
you know succumb to some emotions nah
pick yourself up and go and get a job
straight like i i tell my young my own
ways all the time
there's
i've got a friend who comes to mind
immediately this man cannot live without
a girl like he's a young man he's an
able-bodied man but he jumps from
relationship to a relationship
and and it got to a point where he was
with one of his ex-girlfriends i saw
this two years before it started she was
she was a straight head leveled girl
went to work was never a weekend girl
i said and he was a weekend guy always
out doing drugs smoking drinking he had
no ambition and i set him it's only
amount of time before she leaves you
because you're not displaying the
masculine qualities that every woman
wants especially when they get high in
the corporation leather
lo and behold it happened
so as a result of that i can't tell him
to just comfort him with with beautiful
words to say oh it's going to be all
right fix up it's just
i think i think with that i don't
disagree with you i think men need
a lot especially the men nowadays they
need a step-by-step process
when you talk about um
andrew tate that's the reason why you
know he literally
had
young boys in the palm of his hand and
still does he resonates as a matter of
fact because they they want that they
want and he
i'm not sure with his guideline to get
that because i don't subscribe to it
personally because i've found my own
lane every man needs to find their own
lane there's a perfect example i like to
look at biblical stories because it
really explains the mantra of life at
times
in the beginning in the bible when god
created adam
the first thing he showed him was
himself
he created relationship with god the
second thing he showed adam
was the garden
he gave him purpose
he gave him a drive he gave him a means
of provision
the third thing he showed adam was eve
in contrast do you know what the first
thing got trodi
adam
so men inherently know in order to take
care of a woman you have to have a
purpose you have to find that's why men
struggle to settle when they're not in
any position or provision and you can't
follow the woman's leave otherwise
you're going to eat the apple
she's going to manipulate you some way
it will stay woke man
see the bible is pretty red pearl when
you yo it's real
it really it really is and i know
i don't want to go on a religious
mantra here but in terms of masculinity
and fatherhood i don't think there's
anything better an example of what what
a man is
that's displayed in many biblical
stories
even even even to the point of
polygamous men i mean it ain't the best
example i'm just saying but
uh king solomon was one of the richest
man he's dead and it said plainly in the
while he had many wives
but the rate the way he was able to
cater to many wives was due to resources
this is exactly what andrew tate's
saying it's not news to me like men know
what it takes to get this lifestyle and
if you want to attain to it these are
the steps it's always been like that
it's always been like that okay i'm
going to take a second to read some
super yeah go figure okay okay
um so guys make sure you like the video
as you guys know a like is the most
important metric that youtube uses to
push out in the algorithm
also um all of the super chats are going
towards a new camera so we can shoot in
8k um we also want to get what would you
say eight cameras total
yeah yeah yeah he said yeah um in the
studio where are you gonna put them
everywhere everyone gets a camera
they'll be like oprah like you get a
camera
um okay so um make sure you like the
video and we really appreciate the super
chats it has really helped us up the
studio quality and yeah like this is
we've come a long way right we really
haven't really really from sweating in
that freaking one bedroom
okay um otherworldly oddities tv um bruh
in the socks cap your mom should have
taught you the ways of a woman asking
women to protect a man from other women
is feminine at best mori humans are
absolutely barbaric we haven't changed
much much let civilization break it down
and see how bad things get 90 free toe
pie pie equals apple pie pearl youtube
censors our super chats we have to edit
heavily please read better learn
internet lingo read slower too why did
you skip my question about abortion
remember hitler had 403s mgtow by logic
felons have more kids per capita because
dark triad traits are attractive to
women and are correlated to women
to people who commit crimes so women
don't like criminals they like the
traits but the point stands the stat is
true big breezy
no they're attracted to these type of
men because it's unintegrated and obtuse
dominant behavior as they got older they
look for the same thing but they're
integrated virgins matt butcher spoiled
privileged looked good looks good equals
pain in the ass every single time tim
neuroth i am only going to say this bro
you need to learn how to forgive
forgiveness is the healing of all
problems does it matter who started it
doesn't matter who started it or not
forgive move on be an adult you think
you're you are
you think you are but you're not acting
like one um maury you're allowing your
father to win he still has too much
power over you psychologically learn to
overcome that mental block brother 90
free topi pro choice would you oh i read
that one already okay
wow i just realized the time yeah yeah
um before we get closing um
i just want to ask everyone you can go
around just have your final thoughts um
how essential do you think
fatherhood is for society
100
the most fundamental aspect
of our human structure going forward
as a race of people collectively
go on
yeah just like he said it's
i can't overstate
how
essential a father a male figure but a
father particularly
is in a child's life for both boys and
girls i've got i've got twin boys and a
girl
the way my daughter looks at me
and the way my son looks at me
is a feeling
that and i can never underesti under a
state
when you have a central man in your life
that wants nothing but the best for you
and wants absolutely nothing in return
it gives you the wings that you never
thought you could have and people are
chopping it off in society
men are becoming disposable
and it's doing nothing but downgrading
us debasing our mindsets or creating
more strippers and more felons
and unfortunately this is the reality
and until people realize the importance
of a man a father figure in a child's
life it's always going to be like that
and there's reasons why things go this
in this direction it's clear as day
but
you know people are drinking feminism
calling
next do you um yeah i think fatherhood
is really important i think being a
father isn't just providing though i
think you need to be able to give that
emotional support also to your son and
your daughter like teach a boy how to
become a man and that doesn't mean just
by providing it means teach them how to
protect teach them how to love love a
woman properly teach them everything
that they need to know
so
yeah
i think
in the name of equality and equal
opportunities
i want to see
uh father's day being celebrated just
like mother's day
with gifts with
plankarts all around the city um
we want to see
that
fathers are equally as valued in society
as mothers
until until we have that
women can't expect
to
get all the things that they're asking
for because they're not willing to to
give
it's a give and take
subscribe
thank you yeah thank you guys um thank
you for coming let's see a round of
applause for the panel
um okay so
um while we're talking about the
importance of father shout out dad who
bought me my first soundboard for the
show
shout
i out know if this show would have
happened if my dad didn't you know see
there you go
um okay you have any final things you
want to say um yeah go subscribe to
sarah's channel go subscribe to my
channel first of all on youtube sarah
garvey and also sarah garvey on all
platforms secondly as a i would say as a
fatherless man myself i would say that
fatherhood is 100 essential um in the
society i as a man myself had to find my
own manhood um
through people who i felt were father
figures
and so
that struggle for me to find my own
manhood took longer than it should have
done if i only had had you know a father
around so i'd say yes fatherhood is
essential and i'd like to say also that
if you have watched two or more of our
videos tell them
and you have not subscribed tell them
then we have beef beef what do we have
pal beef exactly you don't want smoke
with me you don't want smoking
no yeah
okay guys um don't forget to subscribe
to the two clips channels just pearly
clips and pearl daily on top of that
sign up i think we did it
i actually don't think we did members
only chat but i swear one of these days
we will do a members only chat and you
will wish you have gotten the five
dollar membership on top of that sign up
for our behind scenes vlog if you want
to see what the penthouse looks like um
blessing when are we filming that
saturday
saturday yeah we're gonna i know i know
we said monday
gaslight we gaslight sometimes
um
third tier connect on social media
fourth tier one-on-one call with me once
a month um this can be either used for
youtube or um you know if you need
advice on a certain situation also go
follow my my instagram just dot pearly
things
and my tic toc just pearly things dot
four and just pearly things dot five i
think they might take away account
number four soon so go follow account
number five but i'm at like 130 k in
like a month they can't get ready they
can't get i'll be back on tick tock you
can't and you know what's funny i go
down my for you page it's just me
another account you can't you can't
um okay on top of that we're almost to
400k so make sure you subscribe to the
channel ring that notification bell so
you know when we are live um tune in for
our members only live that's going to be
next week dm eddie if you want to get on
the show thank you for watching and we
will talk to you next time